20c ottley on cup racers with young
up-and-coming driver's racing
bumper-to-bumper risky maneuvers that
don't always work out well these are the
elements that go to make up the Leon
Euro Cup this year saw 7 race weekends
with the final and séance home country
at the circuit de catalunya in Barcelona
mrs. C Ott's Matias laba says this is
primarily an event for customers these
cars are very desirable but also
relatively affordable making motorsport
more accessible sayit has sold over 180
cup racers not just for the Euro Cup but
also for the TCR series where the car is
leading Belgian title contenders stian
Paulson certainly appeared happy with
the car she's making her the service
package and everything on the updating
stuff um yes it's a good part good
balance card and everything is working
its fall stand for a quite good price Oh
Leon cup racers have the same design
based on the Leon road vehicle let its
wider and uncompromising on aerodynamics
so you got introduced three main changes
for 2016 firstly improved aerodynamics
which has made the car considerably
faster overall and improve the downforce
the car is also more robust in two ways
there's major improvements to the
cooling improving performance when
you're driving in the slipstream of
another vehicle and secondly the car is
more robust mechanically so those are
the three areas top speed cooling and
more robust mechanics making the car
considerably faster and more durable
Snell Owens luck David gonna buy a cup
racer costs around 85 thousand euros add
to that the registration fees for the
season and you're looking at around
100,000 euros this gym to ship is a
championship where our cars are to shame
it's all about setup and Driver and that
wasn't for me the convinced moment
you do Joyce for this alien Europe
Dutchman Neil's Lagerfeld went into the
final knowing only ste on Paulson could
stand between him and the title a few
minutes before the start work was still
being done in paulson's car then the 20
cup racer finalists made their way to
the starting grid
[Music]
I'm 20 points behind it's 25 / win so I
have to win needle stuff to get like
eight or nine or ten positions so yeah
for sure is still open it's nothing is
finished before the shaken flag up the
next race the starting grid offers one
final chance to make any last-minute
adjustments to the car the three top
drivers in the overall standings
including Spain's Mikkel ascona we're
starting from physicians 8 to 10
[Music]
the race was aggressive right from the
start with each driver vying for
position on the first band disaster
struck both Paulson and Lana felt were
forced off the track but the Dutchman
was able to get back into the race
Lagerfeld managed to work his way
forward to fifth place
[Music]
one final tussle on the last lap
Spain's mikelis gonna emerged the winner
from that securing first place in
Barcelona the victory meant he came in
second in the overall standings Neil's
lagerfeld was crowned this year's see
oddly on euro cup champion stian Paulson
took third place overall
you